Emma
just as well the best things
it helps you get smarter exercise your
brain
if I put my mind to something I can do
it and it's not walk right that's not a
go yeah you have to use your head you
have to strategize you have to think you
always have to be light on your feet
when you're doing this
but if you hold you just shake hands
it's a good yeah if I will not get to
feel like a winner just club is really
long
I decided to bring the chess club into
the school when I got the offer because
we had a chess club that had started
here in a small format and I wanted to
be able to offer that to more students
students are really excited to bring
tits into our schools and to give our
students an opportunity to experience
chess and to learn the kinds of skills I
think that will give them what they need
to be lifelong learners things that it
brings to a student just intellectually
in playing chess and learning how to
think ahead and putting four thought
into what you're doing is just a great
opportunity for any student you can get
a good education with that even though
shuffle playing again it just helps me
think better in chess club I've seen all
positive changes in all students for me
is just seeing the light in the students
eyes it's like hey I can do something
that I can be really proud of whenever
the kids are talking about chess their
emotions are excited happy confident it
makes them feel really good because
they've learned a new skill every move
is a countermove every reaction is a
kind of reaction you have to think
what's coming next after I move this
piece they feel brilliant about it which
is so awesome to me because when you
feel smarter you just carry yourself
just a little different and you exude a
confidence which is awesome so to see
that in the kids is fantastic it's
amazing i love it it's inspiring to me
because I identify with many of the
students in terms of the experiences
they're having and they have had and the
expenses out here you get an edge on
learning and how to become a pro
businesses now it's an element that the
community feels connection to the school
with and while that grow students are
bringing it out to their community
through their parents and family and
friends it's like this really positive
connection between the home in the
school chess is a small step in making
them become a better citizen it forces
them to make a plan you have to plan
your next move so they can actually take
this skill into life I think that will
help them a lot it's going to build
confidence it's going to build social
skills it's going to build academics
it's going to allow students to be more
amazing than they already are and really
just expand their horizons others like
no us was champion or so that this grant
gave us such a great opportunity to put
it in the hands of almost triple
students we were serving prior to this
my calls there's be good enough to beat
one of the mascots to all the people
that have helped support this you're
doing a great thing it keep supporting
it make it bigger make it better get it
in every school because every child
needs the opportunity to get to do
something like this I would like to
thank them for the investment because
after all that has taken place you know
throughout Ferguson I think they needed
something they needed some sign to see
that okay people are still interested in
us they have faith in us and they know
that we can accomplish some things I
would really like to thank them for that
thank you thank you thank you we are
thrilled
you